[Music]
hello and welcome to
insane and endgame it's gonna be insane
it's gonna be intense
you guys are gonna have a lot of fun and
i'm dorotheani with ben simon also
helping out um so
i hope you just watched um the chestnut
psychology lesson and are just joining
us from there
so for those of you who wonder in that
last five minutes
i inhaled a half a donut and i
refilled my tea so i'm all charged to go
um
all right so i i have
last week we did a lot of this kind of
weird slash cute puzzles that i think
you guys enjoyed so i'm gonna go ahead
and show
more of those i have 20 of them prepared
if we
somehow need more i always have more you
guys know that i have like
50 000 puzzles um in
one of my databases i just keep adding
on to whenever i see a cool position so
we're never going to run out of puzzles
not in this lifetime
maybe my offsprings will but i've been
reading on evolution a little
so besides that we are going to have a
lot of fun with these
there's going to be some fun still
nights fun draws fun
weird wins the idea is that i want to
keep it as insane and intense as
possible
so let's go what do you think white
should do
here
i did not manually collect fifty
thousand no i had about the
first thirty thousand of it kind of
handed to me
there was like this humongous database
called 26
000. uh it's like studies and end games
and i believe some of these are
directly from that i have no idea who
the author is because
it was just handed to me growing up when
i was
i think in 2012 or 13.
um so yeah keep that in mind
but i kept adding on to it so i hope you
guys enjoy it
keep in mind if you start with bishop c2
um
first of all black doesn't have to take
it second of all if bishop c2 black
takes it
how would you get rid of the rook that's
kind of the problem
no that's that's not it's not going to
work if bishop c2 queen c2 you keep
giving check the king will come to the c
file or the second rank and you are
going to run out of checks
i like that the chat is somewhat
answering themselves i'm loving it
kind of but there are few that are real
games
uh at least the next 10 or so is just
compositions
all right so i'll give you a hint there
is only one move that draws
and it is not the move with bishop to c2
bishop certainly is like your second the
the goal
is that i want to trick you into taking
my rook
so then i do bishop c2 but it's not
exactly a trick whereas in
i'm trying to persuade you there we go
actually let me show you why bishop c2
doesn't work that might be easier
take now depending on where you go let's
say rook goes to h4
just like mu you go over here first of
all queen can take
second of all you go over here it's king
f6
check king e5 you are gonna run out of
checks to give because of this diagonal
i'm assuming even king g5 works because
if check king goes to f5 because of
check
i'll just go back to e5 um
if somehow trying to say if we gave
check from the other side what about
that
now the king can't just go to g6
check king e5 king f5 if check again
king f4
and we are out of checks
this is a very important diagonal so
that's kind of why this doesn't work
bishop c2
all right manage seems to be up to
something why do you like bishop b3
all right i like the idea of bishop
going to b3
because um if you were to take it
now i can give you this check okay move
then whoops now i have to go up there
king moves
now again i can give you check
king moves check can moves check i have
this
all this to for myself to give you check
there's
no queen on c2 to take away my squares
um let's see what if i check you from
the other side
again i can do that again i can do that
but now you're a little busted
so you have to make sure you give check
in the right way
you want to be able to give check
indefinitely
so you don't want there to be a square
so honestly take i think this is the
easiest way and just
keep checking in these file and that
that should be it
uh if he doesn't take if he plays take
over here
bishop c2 kaboom you take and draw
that was fun right a little insane what
about this one
good luck
if there are ever questions about a
previous puzzle just let me know and we
can always go back
it's a little hard i agree
so to answer i manny um
from what i can think of you would have
to get to a3 by b4
but if i give you like rook h5 king
before i have rook b5
also i'm annie um that's kind of the
problem because you can't really come to
the
uh the the b file because i'll always
have rook b
somewhere and then you would have to
take it with the king otherwise you
would lose your queen
okay what about this one i see some
ideas with giving up the queen
so we kind of do want to give up the
queen but
make sure that you're giving it up in a
in a good way
queen of chains he just takes it then
what if rick is too he has no obligation
on taking
it also rook h2 if takes
then they would have to take back with
the king so
i know right it's still silent
everybody's thinking
all right so i'll give you a little hint
this queen is a little too far to give
us stillness we needed to come a little
bit closer
maybe somewhere around here this should
give you a little more ideas
but you can't do queen a2 right now
because queen a2 rook takes it the
queen a2 a2 or k2 you can just play f3
and you are
busted
i do enjoy that the chat is kind of
answering each other i think that's such
a great thing
because it kind of saves me a little
time
to address every single question
yeah manny she got his rook edge do
first i want to give you some
funny check ideas
if you take it now i'm just going to do
you take and well i draw
now it's funny because if you don't take
it let's say you are
too just ignorant and you play queen e3
now check now check
now another check
now maybe another took over here for you
maybe another
one for you um
i kinda wanna maybe queen
c6 king b2 let's do this okay
now i just wanna do checkmates see
if you give your opponent's activity
and the unnecessary the peace activity
and all these ideas with checks and
everything
it's gonna be very painful for you so
guys don't do that don't give your
opponents happiness
all right so what about this one black
to move
oh i see you guys are looking at the
results
good well if you know black's gonna win
how are you gonna do it
uh let me give you a little head start
there are different things that white
could do
let me just tell you if what if white
played king d2 let's just go from there
let's look at this position first
yeah before easily does when get your b4
get your c3 if k goes to b3
now you can easily do c4 because you
can't take it i'll have c2
if you play king c2 now i'll just wait
i'll just wait if you push pawn i'll
just
be going king up uh if you don't push
pawn
again i'll push my pawn again the same
idea
eventually you are going to run out of
moves but now what about this position
keep in mind if we take both of these
pawns this is
going to be a draw so we can't take both
of the pawns
so what should we do
anybody sees some cool ideas some stuff
to do with the ponds
yeah well fun fact this is not
forced you can do this cool idea of a
checkmate
that was kind of something that i really
wanted to show off
all right let's move on to some cool
draws
all right so why to move do you think
white can win this
again to be fair i know that it says
draw up there but still
it doesn't mean that this is going to be
a draw we did look
at some interesting queen versus stroke
ideas on in our end games
um i believe last week but it doesn't
necessarily mean that
you still can't do the best moves you
should do the best moves and then
wait for your opponent to mess up
also i'm a little curious anybody's else
school
college um starting next week
like end of january because i find
that's extremely
weird
i've had my school starting mid-january
most of the times but
this time it's just yeah i mean i
understand that they don't want
they want uh less time with less kids on
less time with more kids on campus there
we go
well most of the school starts i want to
say maybe about
um for second third week of january
uh my school is starting 28 and then
like it's a thursday so i'll
go to school for thursday and friday and
then i that's all for january it's a
little funny
yeah most of my classes are are online
anyways
so
all right so i see some ideas with queen
if any of you remember our lessons last
week you remember queen g5 is the way to
go
generally when this pawn structure is
the problem is if you played queen to d7
there is this weird g5
if take now rook g6 and now this is a
mini fortress you cannot penetrate it
um if king goes to d4 same idea
g5 and either row goes to g6 or king
goes to h7
similar thing this with the rook on
sixth rank with the king over here
it's a fortress um
one more thing to look at is that when
we play queen g5
what do you think is the best move for
black
keep in mind that white still has this
extra pawn so we would like to push it
and you would like to put it to good use
but how
don't necessarily have to take it though
all right so i gave you guys a little
bit of hints that white wants to play h5
so i want to play this h5 so you should
stop me you should move your king away
king h7 if you played king chain g8 i
would have h5 and now again
these ideas are piling up
so you should play king h7 so if h5 now
you can just take
ah take tank and just king g7
now this is again a draw seventh rank
pawn
six drink
so in this position let's say king goes
to c5 again
you will keep your king right around
here just keep moving this bad boy
all right even if checked just king goes
away if h5
again there is take we want
our rook to also be protected
all right great thank you estefan
alrighty i understand that queen end
games are not
the happiest type of end games i don't
feel them either
it's a little queen versus especially
it's just
one of those painful ones
so what do you think
if you guys want to make it a little
more exciting we could
just crop this part out so no more hints
for you guys
i kind of like that idea no more hands
for you guys
you won't know if it's a draw if it's a
win if it's gonna be a
double loss
yeah let's give them a little more
excitement
sure
all right so you guys already know about
this one for next one we're going to
take away
your hands woohoo
so what do you guys think what do you
think should be the move do you only
have
one move that you draw one move one of
jaws
everything else you would be
washing the dishes i don't know that's
kind of a
persian slang that my mom would use
whenever
i was lost not in chess just generally
when there was like an only move in life
and i wouldn't find it
anyways um so what do you guys think
what's your one move
nope knocking f2
not g3
the problem with g3 is a king s3 if you
moved
there now there's this nasty h4
if you take boom bam mate if you don't
take he'll take it he'll take it and
then he'll eat
every single pawn that you hold dear
um so not g3 the problem with king f2
does anybody want to tell me
what's the problem with king f2
maybe i can make it more interesting if
you tell me what's the problem with king
of two
you survive you are not washing dishes
night type of deal you're good no need
to wash this
i need a dishwasher man
i'm so tired of washing dishes
okay yes g3 you guys got it
on g3 the pawn takes it and if we take
over here
king is tree this poor guy falls even if
you play g4
take take you take
and this one will fall too yeah
king goes up just keep g3 and that's a
passport
all right so we're back to this position
we said no to this
and after that a stream is also off the
table automatically
so we're kind of left with king h1 king
h1 is best because if you played f2
now play g3 and now this is a still meet
but that that's why you shouldn't play
this f2 what if g3 what if you play g3
now what do we do
yes h3 is the way to go be careful do
not take this
because now you still have a bunch of
moves you want to be able to box your
king
you want to do this ff2 draw if take
take this is funny now black doesn't
have anywhere to go
all right great let's move on to the
next one
white to move now what about this one
can white i want to say
not to lose this let's go with not
losing
make sure you calculate and make sure
you actually
make sure you actually keep in mind
what your opponent wants to do
i know right if this end game is if i
have five minutes on my clock and this
end game is
with me i probably would spend four
minutes and 30 seconds here
it is right to move
i think the first thing to notice is
that your king is already way too far
behind to be able to make it in time
that's true no no mating for white i
agree with that
so i see the idea of knight c3 after
flew first of all tell me what's wrong
with if you played knight f2
g3 i agree knight f2 does not work
because
g3 whoa g3 knight h3
f3 and you can't stop them both
all right uh same idea with king d5
just push and that's about it too
so that's why you have to try and get
your knight somewhere that can control
more squares
where better than center so let's go
knight c3
now what if you played f3 just knight e4
stopping these two bad boys you push
here i'll just eat this
in the 90s tree you push
here i'll just eat this and well this is
already controlled
so knight c3 let's say f3
oh sorry let's say g3 now what do you do
knight f2 is not a draw knight f2 and
the beginning position is not a draw
nope no knight b5 your knight's getting
too far sorry sorry
uh knight d5 is possible but uh what can
you tell me what's wrong with knight e2
first
because if knight e2 worse than no need
to think about knight far weight on b5
now b5 does work i agree
thank you graceful but if knight b5 king
moves knight d4 you kind of stop
this good uh similar idea with knight e2
the 92 is just it feels a little bit
more straightforward because i'm already
attacking your pawn
if you play g2 knight g1 that's about it
if you play f3 i'll just take over here
and that's it too
all right so yep that's
the puzzle let's go move to avoba
oh that is gonna be wait
this feels too familiar for me
no no we're good
can white win this
there was graceful if there was nice b5
and knight e2
the pawn is going that way
make sure you think about your checks
ah yes let's see if this is a win
we want to be able to trade the queens
but
can we how
well if you played queen b4
um let's say king moves uh so just like
king goes to a1
queen f8 um then just queen d5 and this
will be perpetual
i see a lot of ideas about you guys
feeling this is a draw
maybe let's give it another
minute or two and before we dive a
little deeper into it
all right so to be fair this is a draw
you guys are correct i was just teasing
you a little bit
well i wasn't teasing you over was
teasing me and i teased you
so um
if you were to there's no way to
actually win this but
there is a way there are ways to make
your opponent's life a little
more complicated for example this idea
with queen b6
king a1 check and then trying to go to
f7
but the problem is again queens d8 and
then queen goes to h3 and you're not
going to be able to get rid of
all these checks so that's another idea
that you could potentially work on
and try to see if your opponent can
actually find the best move or not
um the other idea is the one that we
just mentioned with uh trying to play
maybe with the king educate a little
modification i want to give you a queen
but
just queen goes to e5 to be fair again
queen street is a draw whoops queen h3
is a draw to adjust check check check
um king keep here
[Music]
oh hold on hold on my bad this is not
well this is a still draw too
but a easier way just check over here
you have to take it and
still meet can i show a way to lose yeah
of course
there you go boom there's a way to lose
the pawn on b is a lost if the k the paw
was on
a or c that would be a draw easy way to
lose all right what about this one
draw when white to move pawns are going
those
ways
oh
okay well
you as white have one way to save the
game
everything else loses
i told you this today would be insane
and intense
now for those of you who are saying draw
where do you think we should go
and no king b4 is not
the way
i like this this is a little torturous
so let's look at king d2 for example if
king goes to d2
king up uh hold on here actually there
is king c1
so the the the thing is that black wants
to get his king
to f3 and get over here but at the same
time black wants to play strategy
strategically so he wants to be close
enough that
if your king gets too close to the king
side then he goes and eats this pawn
so it's just a game of strategy of how
he which one he can eat faster or better
so um if king goes to d2 there's this
ideas with
one of one of these three moves
let's say you go king g7 let's say you
play king e2
now king goes to e2 how many squares are
away from this pawn
one two three four how many is hit away
one two three
four but when you get here king will be
on
a five so let's say king goes to f6
i wanna go up and i could go down
if you play king d2 now how many squares
on my way one two three
one two three all right so i still am a
little too far away
so let's just go with king f5 now if
king goes to e2
now um
now i can actually go eat that
i am right on time
boom um
yeah now white is definitely losing so
let's go back
to here king f5 let's say you play king
d1
but now again you are one two three four
square away but i'm only three
so let's say you go up now you are
unable to block me from coming to f3
boom king f3 that guy is mine that's why
white has to play it
super accurately so you have to
calculate i showed you why king d2
doesn't
work but i want you guys to calculate
what actually works
because if you go up then you might be
too far away from this guy
uh can you go here can you go here well
you basically have
without king do you have three uh charge
four viable options which one
is the right one only one works only
one
feel free to correct yourself in the
chat too you can
brainstorm off of each other you can
answer each other i would absolutely
love that too
so keep in mind king c2 what if black
just plays king to h6
kills it kills one move with trying to
get it a little closer
always if even if they are they're not
getting it correct
let's start i'll give you guys another
minute while
um you're still thinking
so the idea of going back and forth is
an interesting one but king beether is
not it's
king b3 king goes to g7 you go back now
just king can't go to g6 i still
maintain my distance from both of the
pawns i need one two three four to eat
this to attack this i need one two three
four to attack this
this like kind of golden idea king d2
because you need one two three to stop
me from coming to f3
sorry sorry you need one two three to
stop me from
coming to f3 let's say now i can go k2f7
or f5 let's just go to f5
whoops now if you go to e2 you're too
far away from this guy if you go up
you're too far away from this guy
so that's kind of the problem
it's so weird because your king is never
gonna be
right on time unless unless
you go to
nope b2 exactly i was kind of hoping
somebody would say it when i was saying
unless
it was dramatic a little cinematic nice
yes king b2 is the move it's so weird
because when you go
king g7 my critical squares are
c3 d2 c2 these are my critical squares
so all i'm going to do is just sit away
sorry
sit away i'm going to do a sit
if you go to g8 i'll make fun of you by
going to a1
if you go to f7 just king b2
depending on where you go you come to f6
now i'll just go to c2
when you play king f5 i'm ready to go to
d2
i don't have to move these kinks
anywhere else from d2
if you play king to g4 alright i'll stop
you
if you go to e6 all right i'll come up
with you
this two squares of d2 and f5 are kind
of the killer ideas
um first move there's a question why not
king b2
why not king b2 king g6 you can
but i would just play king c1 i the idea
is i don't want to play king d2
until you play king f5 those are like
the uh the bombs
bump squares wait there's a different
thing mine squares
like you know if you step on it boom
but not the fun boom
i know the persian name for it i'm
pretty sure it's
mints i could let me just look it up
this is bugging me a little
i'm trying mine thank you
i thought i was talking different
language
it's just mean it's like you step on the
men and
oops land mine probably
makes more sense
all right so these two squares are those
two squares you
step on it before your opponent does and
you are not much of you going to be left
so yeah we want king f5 first before we
do king d2
that's the whole idea of this puzzle and
for that reason i'm
willing to go all the way to a1
oh conjugate that just reminds me of
acid-base chemistry
any question on this puzzle before we
move on
all right i'm gonna go ahead um
this one you guys might enjoy this one a
little more
elvis no i will not be on twitch after
this
i have to go attend to gmpg he's been
very vocal singing all night
yeah i have to actually review my
acid-base chemistry
this weekend i am quite terrified of it
so i'm glad that chat feels the same
i agree if it's black to move that's
going to be a mate in one fun
stuff but it's not it's white to move
the trick with the previous puzzle was
that
you had to try and figure out um
that well to be fair and not necessarily
your opponents would play
every single move correctly but as
as long as you understood that the f5
and d2 squares in the previous puzzle
wear those poisoned landline blah blah
squares
you would try to do your best to avoid
them
and you could easily try and find um
to that extent and then king b2 might be
a little
too much you know
you might be surprised the white
actually does have a chance to win
depending on how black plays though but
so you guys have it correct you have to
take this first
if you take with the king i will take
this and i'll make it
into a knight i'll give you check my
bishop is also defending it and then
i'll take over here
and that has a good chance for whites to
win
good chance not winning there's a good
chance there's a difference
so if you take with queen again
kaboom checkmate what if king goes to a8
because now if you take and make a queen
i'll just take it over here
and now this is going to be a still
matrix d1
so what if king goes to a8
still made yeah just is cruel
anybody else yeah we gotta do a rook
promotion
you take make rook king moves
i'll take that i have it this guy extra
that guy extra
that's a lovely position all right
finally we have one win let's see can we
try and squeeze in few more
main question here is a little bit more
theoretical
again wise to move do you think white
can
win this is this a winnable end game
for whites
check him to death i wish that was that
easy
also i wish i could do that to my mcat
yeah i was while you guys are still
thinking about this i'll tell you a
tiny bit of um
weird humor so recently i've been trying
to find study buddies who are actually
also studying for mcat
take it in either march or may
preferably me
and some of my friends who are actually
like classmates are doing
mcat but none of them are actually
studying for it
so one of them is but different
different program
so i've been trying to like group up
with them and
yesterday i was a little desperate and i
was disclosed to go on craigslist and
put an ad
for anybody want to study mcat with me
i didn't do that but the idea actually
came into my mind and i
talk to people about it but anyways
just letting you know that checking
checking it to death
is definitely a thing
actually it's not the worst um yes
what's up ghost of beauty
it is a draw i agree with you when it's
queen and rook
there is usually going to be some weird
draws left and right
so even if you play this correctly and
you keep the king cut away from the rock
there is this rookie he7 that helps the
king try to run
that's why it's a draw if you could keep
if the if like
let's say if you try to move the king
away
let's say he would just play it wrong
and if he gave enough
room for you to try and
attack this king and rook then you could
actually
have some hopes for this position but
the problem is that he will just keep
his
rookie and king right next to each other
all right what about this one can i win
this with white
yes that is also true exquisite if that
pawn didn't exist
my king would be somewhat free to come
and
assess my queen
so ghost of beauty is asking if a king
can pawn and i just have a king can i
stop it from
becoming a queen depending on the
position there are a lot of
uh drop king and pawn end games the best
thing that i learned from king and pawn
and games
where the easiest ones were from the
duborski and games
that i actually have been teaching that
on our twitch channel since i want to
say almost
a little a little less than a year i
think i started teaching those in april
for the king and pawn warfare
it's been quite fun we've had a lot of
fun with our
kings and pawns
all right so i see some ideas with rook
me one i see some ideas with drug a1
um good question do we want to try and
push the g or d
pawn so they're all valid questions the
thing is i'll tell you what
is wrong with rook b1 the problem is
knight goes to a4 even if you do this
rook e1
bishop c6 so that doesn't help you
we want to take away our opponent's
piece activity this knight looks so
cute here i want to keep it here i don't
want to let it fly away
so how what else
oh great wolf was thinking good
i like it rook c8 activate the rook now
where can this poor guy go you go here
i'll go there
you can't go here i'll eat it you can't
go here or here i'll eat it
you go to g2 there's rook c2 you go to
f3
is rook f8 what about bishop h1
anybody
yes your close to that shade good good
and then again you can't really go any
of these squares
f3 there is there there's there that i
eat so you go here there's rook b8
so if rook goes to c6 now i have this
new shiny square for me to go to
that's why it's a win good job guys this
was actually a very nice puzzle i hope
you enjoyed this
let's try to squeeze in maybe one or two
more this should be a little easier so
it goes to beauty this might help answer
your question too
so try to do um
try to do
it's whiting so try your best to see can
white win this
i agree right that was such an empty
board and it still got
a little ugly
okay so i'm seeing some nice ideas
coming in
sacrificing the pawn yes wise can win
yeah it's about the idea of breakthrough
you guys got this
c5 kaboom if you take
hello new queen if you don't take and
you play b5 now just push
push keep in mind we can easily bring in
our king
no need to be a hero just go don't try
to let your opponent make a queen this
is something that i've actually seen a
lot of players
do do this as a mistake they just push
and even though yes this still you do
end up with an extra pawn this is so
so so hard to win don't do that just do
take a5 sorry just do it push
push just bring your king voila easy
peasy don't make your life living hell
don't do that there we go what about
this one
why is to move can white win this
all right i see some ideas coming in
all right somebody's saying it's a draw
i have to disagree
king d6 is a good move you are confusing
your opponent
if king g5 now i'll just go king e5
and then i can just make it into a nice
shiny queen
if take well that's for that if take
king goes up
um the idea is that king d6 the problem
is kind of that
um even if you play rook b8 then
i can simply play kink to c7
we have looked at a similar position
with this uh
weeks ago the idea was that you just
shouldn't get your king to seventh rank
and the only trick that black could do
is try to wait for you to get your chain
to the seventh track
so because if you play this now take and
check and well
i'll take your other one so yeah there
are a lot of cool tricks here
um i will be sharing this link with you
guys
i think this was such a great study feel
free to check them out
i really did enjoy our
today's session we had some nice uh tata
still
going on we got some insane slash
intense end game going on
um make sure to join me for
tomorrow's twitch channel playing the
viewer and
after that just frequently look us up
on twitch and youtube uh thank you for
joining me tonight which is on
psychology
and insane and endgame have a good rest
of your night
you